announced yesterday for the state's
vaccine incentive program it's called
vax nevada days so many winners had
their moment of
fame or notoriety along with their prize
but that left many wondering how the
process works
christian koster has joined us live in
studio to eliminate
any confusion well brian it can be
confusing if you watch the live drawing
but there is
another side of the event that many of
us don't see and here's how it works
fairness and security are cornerstones
of the vax nevada day drawing
that's according to immunized nevada
executive director heidi parker
who explained the layout during the
weekly covet update with
state and local health officials she
says immunize nevada and the state
take every step possible to ensure the
integrity of the process
which is overseen by the nevada gaming
control board that is compromised
of the industry's most trusted and
trained regulators in the world
now the program uses igt which is a
gaming service
which is donating time and resources to
protect the integrity of the drawing
necessary steps parker says to keep
everyone's privacy
protected during the live event
hipaa laws protect patient rights so we
must secure
permission to release the identities of
winning coven 19 vaccinated patients
and finally some of our winners are
between the ages of 12 and 17
and are winning tuition prizes so we
must first secure parental consent
parker added that cash and tuition
prices are drawn for
all eligible nevadans in advance of the
thursday live reveal
winners are notified of their winning
status but they are not told
the amount now during the thursday live
reveal every nevadan
that has their name read or appears in
person to get that prize on tv
well they've already granted permission
it's a very unique process but
organizers say
it's the best way to keep everyone safe
christian casadas 8 news now